in 2012 I wrote a book called finding
ultra it chronicles my experiences my
journeys through alcoholism and
ultimately sobriety it's about how I
changed my relationship with food to
restore my vitality and it's about my
experiences in the world of ultra
endurance triathlon but that was just
one chapter of my story it was never
intended to be the complete story what
has occurred in my life since then is
far more compelling and I wanted to
share that this revised second edition
of the book contains a bounty of brand
new information based on my experiences
over the last 6 or 7 years along this
journey that I've been on I have had the
opportunity to hear from and meet so
many people all over the world and most
of these people they're not triathletes
or ultra runners there are average
everyday people just trying to figure
out how to live and be a little bit
better they're interested in how to get
unstuck from a career that doesn't serve
them or a relationship gone awry Henry
David Thoreau said the mass of men lead
lives of quiet desperation it's true
it's tragic but it's also unnecessary so
I wanted to provide a framework a
roadmap to help people learn how to live
with more conscious intention more
mindfulness more purpose so that they
ultimately can lead more fulfilling
lives
[Music]